c'est un document vieux de cent
vingt-neuf ans est rédigée par paul
cézanne qui vient d'être remis à la
directrice des archives départementales
c'est la signature très important un
document captivant parce qu'il énonce
clairement la condition des femmes au
19e siècle et particulièrement celle de
hortense fiquet dont le père réside est
à l'antenne vers tiers dans le jura
après son mariage avec le peintre elle
s'appellera désormais madame paul
cézanne pour le meilleur et pour le pire
c'est une procuration qui a été signé
par monsieur paul cézanne qui autorisait
sa femme à vendre les terrains qui lui
appartenait à elle parce que jusqu'en
dans les années 60 la femme pour signer
des actes notariés
même si c'était pour vendre ses biens
elle devait demander l'autorisation de
son mari
cet autographe est l'un des seuls
documents qui rattache le peintre à la
franche comté et particulièrement au
village de l'antenne vers tiers c'est
ici qu'ont vécu les parents d'hortense
sa maman était la fille du forgeron du
village et à la mort de son père en 1889
hortense renommée madame paul cézanne
hérite de ses biens mais ne peut en
disposer librement parfaitement sous
tutelle ou ces ados que moi c'est
consternant mais qui montre bien où
effectivement la situation de minorité
dans lesquels les femmes ont été tenus
jusqu'à quand même il faut le rappeler
1965 puisque c'est en 1965 les femmes
enfin le droit de parents d'ouvrir tout
seul un come back à l'antenne vers tiers
il ne reste plus grandes traces
d'hortense fille qu'elle épouse un
modèle de paul cézanne
si ce n'est cette maison dans laquelle
il se réfugiait parfois à l'abri des
regards
l'artiste il y aurait même pas le verger
sans jamais parvenir à terminer sa toile